So now we have a well defined
computational problem
that's going to model what the mass
spectrometer is telling us.
And here we'll study a first idea of an
algorithm for it.
First, I'll tell you that the mass of
the entire peptide is usually known.
So we'll usually already know that Tyrocidine B1 has mass 1322.
Our algorithm is going to then say,
all right, let's generate every possible
peptide of that mass
so in this case, for Tyrocidine
B1, it’s 1322.
Let's form the spectrum of every one of
those peptides,
and then let's look for matches with the
given spectrum among those peptides.
This is an example of a brute force
algorithm.
In general, a brute force algorithm is
going
to try all possible solutions that satisfy
a certain condition.
So then our question is, to determine how
long is this going to take,
we ask, how many peptides have a given
integer mass?
So in specific, how many peptides have
integer mass equal to 1322?
Here's a graph that shows the integer mass
of a peptide
versus the number of peptides
that have that mass.
And if we look at 1322, I've shown red
lines here, we go up from 1322
and then we go over,
and we see it's almost at 10 to the
14th.
So the answer is, TRILLIONS of different
peptides have this mass.
And that's not going to be good.
We don't want to have to consider
trillions of different possibilities.
So let's ask ourselves, then, what is it
that makes brute force so bad to begin
with?
Or, at least, this brute force algorithm?
Some brute force algorithms may work well,
if they choose a correct condition.
Here's a peptide, NQEL,
that we're going to start working
with,
snd another peptide, TMDH.
The total mass of NQEL is 484,
and the total mass of TMDH is 484.
But they're completely different.
They don't have any of the same amino
acids.
By extension, they're not going to have any of the same
sub-peptides.
And so we need to find a way to exclude
this completely.
We don't want to ever have to encounter this
peptide.
The way that we're going to get at
that
is to say let's look at the spectra of these
two peptides.
So on the left here I've shown the
spectrum of TMDH
and on the right I've shown the
spectrum of NQEL.
They completely disagree.
So you may notice this.
They agree at 0, and they agree at 484.
And nowhere in between do they have the
same two of the same masses.
We want to use this to our advantage.
We want to use this to start designing an
algorithm that's going
to eliminate TMDH based on its
spectrum, which is not good.
So our idea is: rather than try to form
big peptides all at once,
let's slowly
build up our candidate solutions from
smaller peptides.
At each stage, we're going to test its
spectrum,
and make sure it's on the right
track.
And if it's not on the right track, we're
going to kick it out.
That's going to allow us to restrict
the total number of peptides that are under
consideration.